le conflit le plus meurtrier du xxème
siècle fait rage alors que les nations
du monde entier sont sur le point de
s'embrasser un homme va changer à jamais
l histoire ok ok c'est parti alors là
aujourd'hui on est très hype et passe un
jeu sur la seconde guerre mondiale en
réalité virtuelle en prof [ __ ]
s'accumulent tous les facteurs style et
à qui appuient leur mission est bon on
va les faire dans l'ordre talk aim si tu
pars première mission au jeu s'entend
pas agi de mon gars je saute en
parachute tenri rauque et j'attends 10
secondes en 10 secondes mais je dois
sauter c'est robert médias est ce que
vous êtes mon chapeau aux pâquis son
altesse bien de line hockey je suis
derrière chez derrière je suis prêt
cette époque se plaignent c'est parti
c'est trop bien on arrive moche encore
[ __ ] j'ai failli faire tomber modèle
pour ne pas qu'ils tombent sur la tête
d'un allemand aulas la demande a été
plus tard en pleine chute monga bonnes
armes en haut c'est bon ok on en train
d'atterrir
ouais au tracé de maisons à ce quizz
grippe button to pick up web
en fait on va taipei alors peu le bol
back with other hand to reload trigger à
ok je recharge et là je tire un mot 2
non non il m'a vu il m'a vue ils
arrivent ils arrivent ils à un nerf au
charme [ __ ] j'suis avec 19 heures de
remploi pourquoi il m'a envoyé moi dans
le passé sans déconner on l'a au nom
donné en deuxième
voyez là à temps je suis mieux une faune
lunettes à temps mais il va se ramener à
tarnos kokkinos camping martin de coux y
aller pourquoi viser quand on peut juste
faire au jugé
d'ailleurs sans viser oh mon dieu
en plein mouvement on a eu ce qu'on
allait aller suivant j'étais lui je
tiens pas du tout comme un sniper votre
iphone os et beau encore mais arrêter
d'arrimer un moment j'étais tout années
déjà tiens suivant suivant six mois
après mois le french doctor tient
suivant ok hurle au nom même de
mécanique aura encore un ouais là mais
voilà petit peu le stopper et vient de
loin il s'appelle la fouine à mes
vertèbres à c'est fini on a gagné la
guerre tu penses que la main bon bah
voilà à l'est éclair sur la planète
c'est pourquoi je récupère nema et on
fait la deuxième mission alors on est où
là c'est quoi ce délire d'accord on ya
des pierres mais jean paul jean desquels
il faut vraiment que oui il ya de
l'allemand n'est calé au moins il est
haut en saveurs
je lance des pierres à sa marche pas du
tout moyen tour et la géniale a au moins
compris cette occasion qui arrivent mais
non m'apprendre de pierre au cas où oh
mon dieu
hop là dans ton cul tiens je vais très
animé viens viens là c'est pas le digger
haut c'est quoi mais non non et comme
les bouts de chou la france si vous
m'aidez pas à du coup ça des capitelles
ça j'aimerais que c'était un collabo le
capteur mais pas du tout merci oui ok on
arrête les conneries fils de [ __ ] à
l'onema deux parties cachées soient pas
des gains à aller dans les bureaux mon
pote alors vers quoi waouh en plus d'y
arriver est arrivé
non bon gars comme on l'a dépensé
retournerais les palettes intermarché
connard la décapitation de vos hommes
voilà ce qui vous attend ta gueule voilà
merci mais sinon j'attends juste là en
fait si l'on fait les snipers campeurs
ça vous plaît
perdu pour perdu 8 pourquoi avisés de
loin quand tu peux juste camper comme ça
c'est vrai ou pas au plaza dégage
allez on attend suivant hitler vient là
c'est grâce aux dons mais après si tu es
mon bébé
hop là non
mais je suis là ah ben là qu'est ce tu
as peur je tais tu es bien moi je suis
là pour eux alors tu meurs si un pan os
il ya un char mais bon faut faire quoi
consiste votre temps c'est moncler terre
ici tu peux pas test
oui si on arrête la guerre c'est l'heure
du goûter au ces les alliés c'est les
alliés ouais les gars merci les gars
millions m merci à tous et terme en
superbike il nous chercher bon force de
paix dont m ok ce parti je suis prêt
aussi horrible qu'on fait actuellement
là je suis totalement allemand je suis
un chat clown et demi alors pas se
mentir
ok elle a des munitions infinies et pas
de rechargement c'est à dire c'est à
dire quoi passer un bon moment
dès qu'ils avaient de l'eau au dessus de
la ceinture aux américains n'avaient pas
droit à leur tirer dessus voilà c'est
une règle nous finalement on s'en bat
les couilles là on est plutôt qu'une
règle mon gars c'est super dur nike
devise était quoi aller technique du
moulinet j'avais vu plusieurs faire ça
aussi à la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
juste du bolide qui mouline et il n'y a
pas fait dans les notes d'espoir drôle
et bâle je suis le pire alors du gourou
à merde merde merde merde phase in touch
pad ou non mais attends le maître paul
vettier tu m'expliques comment recharger
quoi bon ça l'échec à d'accord ok en
fait tu tires tu recherches et un
chargeur qui apparaît en bas et tu
mélanges dessus et tu peux retirer
ok donc tu vois là la règle de locon à
dix juste avant on va bien respecté
c'est faux
colas et gamma les gars ça se passe
trois voix
ça va arriver dans pas longtemps tu sais
quoi
je propose une alternative mais qu on
campe là on se pose pas et tu vas contre
le muret et on attend franchement stati
gras - ah mais non mais non mort plutôt
à ça commence à arriver au ketchup
on recherche on attend au maire mais
merde et le chien bon bon bon bon mais
en fait c'est impossible visée parce que
pourquoi je fais ça déjà parce que je la
tiens je peut la tenir à distance est
totalement tchité professeur xavier
bonjour c'est moi et ensuite parce que
quand un jour hier dans le bizarre je
suis ébloui par les flashs je vois rien
bord des droits on voit où je prend cher
de au flat mais pourquoi mes potes oeil
mais nous pas [ __ ] hockey nom se cache
et se cacher se cacher ok c'est bon
vieux merville à schengen mais non mais
non il est où il est où j'ai plus de
gueule non attends pouces avec
ça va chier
bousculés non non vous gardez repas la
guerre non c'est comme un peu de tout ça
mais moi je peux tu as jeu provient du
passé que les rocistes sais pas si tu
buzz est amer je tempère
wayne rooney ce que celle d'envoyer le
plus grand des cons dans le passé pour
sauver les alliés n'hésitez pas mais non
ça vous a plu
je te retrouver dans une prochaine un
mois je retourne dans le passé pour
faire foirer encore plus de guerre ce
n'est pas étonné si dans vos livres
d'histoire tout d'un coup il ya marqué
qu'on a perdu toutes les gares
j'en suis responsable a très vite
c'était le père soldat de l'univers